SRINI DEVADAS: How many of
you have attended a celebrity
party?
I haven't.
Well, if you count
MIT professors
as being celebrities, I've
been to a lot of them,
but that's not the case, right?
People don't really think
of us as celebrities,
which is fine with me.
So this puzzle, I call it
the best time to party.
And-- I'm having a little
trouble erasing the--
oh you're right.
There's another one?
All right.
Well, I'm probably going
to run out of this.
But you know what?
This time I'll use--
I don't think I need
this super thick chalk.
There's a slightly--
I'll use this one.
So setup here-- with
all of these things,
there's always a
little bit of setup--
is, you got a ticket
to this party.
There are going to be
all these celebrities.
And it's a timed ticket
with some flexibility.
You only get to stay for
a certain amount of time
before you have to leave
and other people are
going to come in and hobnob
with these celebrities.
But you get to pick the
particular time that you go,
right?
And so, initially,
we'll set things up
in a fairly straightforward way.
We're going to say that you
have an hour, a particular hour,
maybe it's 6:00 to 7:00,
7:00 to 8:00, what have you.
You get to choose.
That's part of the puzzle.
How do you pick the
best time to party?
And you do have a schedule.
And amazingly, these
celebrities are going
to stick to those schedules.
But the schedule has been
published with respect
to when particular celebrities
are going to be at this party.
All right?
And as you can imagine, as the
title of the puzzle gives away,
you want to choose the hour
such that the maximum number
of celebrities-- so you're
not particularly interested
in particular celebrities
or one specific celebrity,
you just wanted sort of
max out number of selfies
so you can put it on your
Facebook page, Instagram,
what have you.
And you have that
schedule and you're
trying to optimize the number.
So here you go.
We're going to have a--
let's just solve this
again manually first,
and then we'll
think of algorithms.
We're going to have
intervals again.
And so think of these as hours.
Beyonce comes in at
6:00, leaves at 7.
Taylor from 7:00 through 9:00.
Brad 10:00 to 11:00.
Katie 10:00 to 12:00.
Tom 8:00 to 10:00.
Going to run out of room here.
All right.
So that's the schedule
that's published, right?
And we can think
of these as hours--
comes and goes.
There's one small
subtlety, which
is, I'm going to
think of these as
closed intervals on the left
end and open at the right end.
So all that means is,
if this is 6:00 PM,
and if you come in at
6:00 PM on the dot, well,
you certainly get
to see Beyonce.
And if you come in at 6:59,
you get to see Beyonce,
but if you come in
at 7:00, she's gone.
Right?
And the same thing
with Taylor at 9:00.
So you you have to choose
your time properly.
So what's the best time?
You get to go for any
hour that you choose.
What's the best
time to go to get
the maximum number of selfies?
Anyone?
You can do this manually.
Tell me what the time
is and then I'll ask you
what your algorithm was?
Right?
So-- someone who
hasn't answered yet.
Yep?
AUDIENCE: Either 6:00 or 10:00.
SRINI DEVADAS: Either 6:00
or-- what's your name?
AUDIENCE: Kevin.
SRINI DEVADAS: Oh!
Kevin.
Right.
Sorry.
You're the other Kevin.
All right.
So-- 6:00 o'clock
or 10:00 o'clock,
because at 6:00 o'clock--
so who are the people
you'd see at 6:00 o'clock?
AUDIENCE: Beyonce
and Alicia Keys.
SRINI DEVADAS: That's only two.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
SRINI DEVADAS: So can
you do better than two?
Can someone do better
than what Kevin did?
Yeah, go ahead.
Kanishka
AUDIENCE: That will be Brad.
So at 10:00, you'll get Brad.
Katy, and Drake.
SRINI DEVADAS: Yes.
So you could do three.
At 10:00, you would get Brad.
You would get Katie, and
then you'd also get Drake.
OK?
So that's three.
So that's the best you can
do in this puzzle, right?
But you may have
hundreds of celebrities
and you want to
pick the right time.
So obviously, we want to write
a computer program here, right?
What algorithm,
Kevin or Kanishka
did you use to do this?
How do you do it in your head?
AUDIENCE: I first
of all saw which
were the good candidates or
shortlisting them essentially.
SRINI DEVADAS: Did you
go, either one of you,
did you go hour by hour?
Did you go 6:00 o'clock--
how many people are there?
Or did you try and intersect,
or what did you do?
What's a reasonable
way of proceeding here?
Right?
What's a reasonable
way of proceeding?
Someone other than--
yeah, back there.
AUDIENCE: Look at the most
frequent amount of time.
SRINI DEVADAS: The
frequent amount of time?
So look at the hours.
You say 6:00 o'clock
and you try and see
how many sixes are up there?
Or-- right.
What's your name?
AUDIENCE: Nisha.
SRINI DEVADAS: So
Nisha says she's
going to go look
for 6:00 o'clock
and see if many
sixes are up there.
Right?
And there's two sixes up there.
And maybe that's why
Kevin said six, right?
On the other hand, clearly that
didn't quite work in this case,
because what happened was,
10:00 o'clock-- there's only two
of those.
And so that looks good,
too, 6:00 and 10:00,
but you missed the fact that
10 exists in 9:00 and 11:00,
correct?
So you're not explicitly
seeing these things.
But that gives you an algorithm.
I mean, it does give
you an algorithm.
The algorithm is--
let me go ahead
and do a little bit better
than what you described,
a little more
relaxed check, right?
It's not just an identical, I
want six to be in the table.
But I want to see
if six is contained
in the interval associated
with any particular celebrity.
Correct?
So if I did six, I'd say six
is contained in this interval.
It's not contained
in this interval.
Not, not, not, not, yes.
Right?
So I'd get two.
And then when I've
finally got to 10,
I'd get contained, contained,
contained, and I'd get three.
Right?
So there's clearly
an algorithm here
that depends on the number of
hours that you're looking at.
Depends, really, on the
granularity of time, OK?
So this particular algorithm
would say, let me go ahead
and enumerate the different
times that I could possibly go.
I could start 6:00.
I could start at 7:00.
But maybe we'll start at 6:30.
I could go from 6:30 to 7:30.
You're allowed to
do that, right?
The point is, if you stick
with the original description,
you could go ahead and
enumerate 6:00 through 12:00,
and then you could generate
a bunch of different numbers
associated with the
number of celebrities
and you could go ahead and
pick what time you want to go.
Right?
So it's a little bit like our
previous puzzle in the sense
that there's a relatively
straightforward strategy that
enumerates different hours
and goes through and does
a bunch of computation and
then picks the maximum,
in this case.
Previously, it was the minimum
for, you will all conform.
Here, it's the maximum, right?
What is a disadvantage of
this particular algorithm
that we just described?
What is one potential
disadvantage?
Yeah?
Go ahead, Fadi.
AUDIENCE: Well, it's
not linear, so you have
to make multiple passes on.
First of all, you
have to enumerate
all of the possible times.
And then for every
time, you have
to go through the list
over and over again.
So there's a lot
of computational--
SRINI DEVADAS: There's
a lot of computation.
There's a lot of
computational overhead.
Let me show you
what the code looks
like for the straightforward
algorithm, all right?
And so it's going to,
again, be intuitive.
It's going to do exactly what
we just described, right?
And so if you look at
what you have up there--
schedule up there is simply
a set of intervals, right?
And they're tuples.
And so I have something that's
bigger than this example here,
but it includes that.
And there's a whole
bunch of things in there.
And now I'm going to look at--
this is just a start time
for a particular celebrity.
This is the end time
for that celebrity.
I'm just setting that up.
And I'm going to go ahead and--
I'm looking at for
each c in schedule,
I'm going to look at this.
I'm going to look at that.
I'm going to figure out what the
start time is and the end is.
And I'm just doing
this simply because I
want to figure out what the
earliest start time for any
of these celebrities are.
So in this case, it's six.
And the latest time that
a celebrity is around
is 12, right?
So that's all of this
first thing does.
It's just finding the range
that I have to deal with.
So there's not much there.
I'm going to go ahead
and compute what's
called the celebrity density.
And I'll show you
the code for that.
But that's essentially
what we describe,
which is for a particular
hour between start and end,
how many celebrities do I see
at that particular hour, right?
And then for the next hour,
how many celebrities do I see?
I'm just calling it
the density, right?
And then, the count
is a list that
is going to have celebrity
densities for particular times
that correspond to
the indices of count.
And I'm just going to
go through that list
and I'm going to figure out
the time that has max count,
or the maximum number
of celebrities.
And there's a couple of
different ways of doing that.
Don't worry about that, but
I'm happy to answer questions
if you have them.
And then, I just
say the best time
to end the party
is at this time.
Time, which was discovered
here, and the number
of celebrities who are going
to be attending is max count.
OK.
So this is essentially the
code for the algorithm.
And this thing here is doing
the slightly more relaxed check
that I alluded to, which
was like when you have 6:00,
you're not just
looking for 6:00 here,
you're looking for 6:00
within this interval
that looks like this.
So 6:00 is definitely within
this, but it would not be--
6:00 is not inside 5:00 and 6:00
as I described to you before,
right?
So that's simply the check.
That's why you have a
less than equal to here
and a strictly greater
than over here,
just to take care of that
closed and open part of it.
So again, if you
don't understand
every nuance in this code,
it's not that big a deal.
But hopefully you have the
overall picture, right?
Makes sense, right?
So as you can imagine,
there's a much better way.
There's a much
better way that isn't
as exhaustive as this one.
And do people have a sense of
what a better way would be,
or would you like a hint?
And anyone want to conjecture
a different way of solving this
problem that's--
yeah, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: The exhaustiveness
of this algorithm?
SRINI DEVADAS: Ah,
so the exhaustiveness
of this algorithm is as follows.
So basically what
I'm saying is--
what I'm saying is I'm going to
go look at the range of times.
And all of these
are per hour, right?
Everything is per hour.
I'm going to look at
the range of times,
and I'm going to go
ahead and include 6:00
through 12:00 here.
And I'm going to
go 6:00, and I'm
going to go figure out at 6:00
how many celebrities exist.
And then at 7:00,
how many celebrities
exist, and then at 8:00 all
the way to 12:00, right?
And I'm going to get in count,
which is that list there, I'm
going to get for each--
for count 6:00, I'm
going to say two.
And for count 10:00,
I'm going to get three,
because 10 is the hour.
And then I'm going to
go through that list
and figure out that 10 had
the maximum number in it.
And that's the
exhaustiveness, right?
That make sense?
So if we're good with
that, this algorithm works.
But it's a little
painful, right?
So what-- any ideas as
to how we could do things
quite differently, which
would be more efficient?
And let me give out the word.
I want an incremental
way of doing this.
How could I do this?
I have a starting
time, and I want
to compute the same densities
in an incremental way.
Someone else other than Fadi?
Yeah, back there.
AUDIENCE: Well, you have to
start the n time thing just
for each list of whatever
tuple or whatever you could
keep like a count--
a different count,
a dictionary of the start time,
and then increment through each
of the start times until the
end and just add one each time.
So you're basically iterating
through each set of times
and finding the
count of each time
and whichever time is the most.
SRINI DEVADAS: You're
absolutely on the right track.
And it turns out you don't
even need dictionaries.
You can do this with
just plain lists.
But the idea here is actually
a very compelling one.
It's something that you'll
see in other algorithms.
Whenever you have something
where you're doing repeated
computation, there's always--
many a time, there's a way of
removing redundancy and turning
into incremental
computation, right?
And so the insight
here is the following.
The only time that
celebrity density, which
is the number of celebrities
that are in the room, changes
is obviously when
a celebrity enters
or when a celebrity
leaves, right?
I mean, that's it.
I mean, we're all
celebrities here.
And I guess we did have
someone leave, so there you go.
And then maybe someone is
going to come in, right?
So I just need to monitor
sort of input and output,
or entry and exit.
And I also know
what the endpoints
are with respect to the 6:00,
6:00 PM versus 12:00, correct?
So what I can do here
is the following.
Suppose I had a chart that
looks like this, right?
And what I'm drawing
here are these intervals.
They aren't exactly
what I had up there,
but I'm drawing those
intervals up, right?
So you could think of this,
if you'd like, as being 6:00.
You can think of
these two lined up
as being 7:00, and
so on and so forth.
So I could draw these out.
And I don't really
have to draw these out
in a computer program, but I
can certainly draw them out
in terms of giving you
the intuition, right?
So what I'm going to do is
I'm going to start with zero.
So before 6:00, there's
absolutely no one in the room,
so I'm at zero.
And the moment I see--
I take one of these things,
and if I see a celebrity,
I can increment the count.
So here at 5:00 I'm at
zero, at 6:00 I get one.
And at 7:00, no one has
left, and two more people
have come in, so I get three.
And now, the next
thing happens out here.
Let's say this one here is
8:00, I would get four for that.
And then out here it's 9:00.
I go 4 minus 1 equals 3,
because this celebrity left.
So essentially,
what I want to do
is not have to compute this over
and over for every time running
through all of the
list of celebrities
like I did before,
for 6:00, 7:00,
through all the
celebrities for 7:00--
I meant through all
the celebrities.
But if I sort the celebrities
in increasing order of start
times, essentially this
picture is important
and it requires sorting, because
I went from left to right.
And when I go from
left to right,
I'm essentially
saying I want to see
things that come earlier before
the ones that come later,
right?
That's essentially what time
goes to the right, right?
So I'm going from left to right.
So if I take these intervals and
I sort them, and basically sort
them by the start times,
then all I need to do
is, in the sorted
list of intervals,
I just showed you
the computation
that we have to perform.
The computation that
we have to perform
is-- this was the first
interval in the sorted list
of intervals, because it
was the leftmost interval.
And I take that and I go ahead
and increment it to one, right?
Then, the next thing
I do is I don't
have to worry about any time.
Even if there was a
time, if this was 6:00
and this was 8:00, for
example, as long as there's
no celebrity that
came in at 7:00,
there's no reason for
me to change anything
in my data structure, right?
The only times that
are interesting
are when celebrities
enter and leave.
So the other nice thing
about this algorithm
is that it will
work if Beyonce came
in at 6:39:39, 39 seconds--
39 minutes, 39 seconds
and left at 6:51 whatever,
because I'm only
concerned with the entry
of a celebrity and the
exit of a celebrity
that correspond to these points
that you see here, right?
Does the algorithm make sense
from an intuitive standpoint?
Do you see what's
happening here?
Hopefully the picture
gives you a sense
for how you're doing
the correct computation.
And the only times
that things change
are when-- at the end points
of these intervals, right?
When you see someone, increment,
and when someone leaves,
decrement, right?
So this set of numbers
that you generate
is essentially the
density down at the bottom
that corresponds to, at
particular times, not
necessarily on the hour, but
whenever the celebrities come
and go.
And so that list
that you get is all
that you need to look at to
figure out what the maximum is,
right?
So ultimately down below,
in this particular example,
perhaps four was the maximum.
And it started with zero.
It climbs up, maybe goes to
four, maybe goes to five,
and then goes down again,
maybe climbs up again.
Who cares?
Once you get to the point where
you've written the program,
size doesn't matter
anymore, right?
So the last thing
I'll do is I'll
show you the code for this.
It will be up on the website.
And feel free to
come to office hours
and ask me questions
about the code,
or before lecture tomorrow.
But this is the
entirety of the code.
And I'm not even using the built
in sort functions in Python.
I went ahead and wrote
it just to give you
a sense of how long
the code would be.
But it's a much more
elegant algorithm.
It would run faster
on large examples.
And I don't want to get
into asymptotic complexity.
That's really beyond this class.
But as you can imagine,
rather than going
through the list of
celebrities over and over,
we're actually doing
sorting exactly once, right?
So that's better.
But essentially, what
happens here is simple.
You go ahead and you
create each of these times.
So this is particular
celebrity, particular time,
and this is the start
point of the celebrity.
So you have to mark that.
This is very
different from that.
What happens here
is I am adding.
is I'm subtracting.
So I have to know
whether this point is
very different from that point.
This is the same as
that, same as that.
And all of these
are similar, but I
have to differentiate between
the two for obvious reasons.
So I have to have start and end.
And then I go ahead
and take these times.
Each of these times that you
see with these black dots
here, they all
need to be sorted,
because that's the only
way I'm going to go from
left to right, right?
That's the only way, by going
through that list of times.
So I'm going to go ahead
and do that sorting.
And I could have done
times dot sort by the way.
I don't have to have sort
list, but I just, as I said,
I wanted to show you
the code without using
any Python library functions.
And then choose time is simply
looking through that list,
finding that maximum
number, be it four or five,
and returning the index of
that, because that tells you
what the particular time is.
And that time will always be--
can someone tell me?
Last question and
I'll let you go.
What am I going to get--
on any given example, what
am I going to get as the
best time, any given example?
I'll get you if Ganatra.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: A time when more
people come and leave.
SRINI DEVADAS: A time when
more people come and leave.
That's correct, but I
want something stronger.
What's your name?
AUDIENCE: Josh.
SRINI DEVADAS: Josh?
Yeah, Josh is right,
but I want something
even stronger than a time that
more people come than leave.
I mean, it's correct, but
a variant observation.
Someone else?
I want to say something about--
there's two sets of
points here, right?
There's two sets of points here.
Which set of points
are going to be
the ones that are in play, with
respect to the maximum time.
That's maybe a better question.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: The arrival
time of someone.
SRINI DEVADAS: That's right.
That arrival time of
a celebrity, right?
And it's true that what you
said, George is correct.
Ultimately, the
best time is going
to be when the maximum
number of arrivals happen.
But the bottom line is,
I'm never going to--
this is actually an
interesting observation,
and there's an exercise
related to this observation
for this puzzle
that you might want
to look at that I'll
put up on the website
as soon as we're done here.
You're always going to pick
one of these beginning times,
because that's when
the increment happens.
You'd never pick one of
these, because that's when
a decrement happens, right?
So that's all I wanted to say.
And the reason I wanted
to say that, as I said,
there's an extra question
on top of this, and yet
another algorithm
to solve this that
is really based on that final
observation that we made.
All right.
Well, thank you.
Sorry for going over, but
as I said, this is IAP.
Forgive me.